dear white people
here's a list of acceptable Halloween
costumes a pirate [ __ ] nurse any of
our first 43 presidents top of the list
of unacceptable costumes me Winchester
couldn't get through 2017 without
blackface
oh I'm sorry am I being too loud for you
you know I say woke Sam but right now
I'm getting the tianhao to be wasted and
a [ __ ] from this white [ __ ] in Texas
okay one year Gorge and two is white
[ __ ] in Texas or government name her
name's Marion Updike she's a found
overthink some online course and she'd
be dropping the knowledge I need to drop
my sophomore 16 not a thing right now
I'm learning how to enjoy a decadent
McRib miss Updike told me to cut it into
fourths and cut my choose 30 by the way
I'm pretty sure the McRib was invented
by Republicans in the 80s to destroy
black communities along with crack and
Jerry Springer suck it Reagan I'm still
here and please note that I will be
showing up on McRib day initially
Chisholm t-shirt songs and channel
conflict is McRib dancing and where are
you getting me shirley Chisholm t-shirt
421 girl you know I have no shame
Oh